Julie Stout: Okay, I think we are recording.
Julie Stout: Hello? I am Julie Stout once again, and I'm here with Rick March, and we are here for part 3 of our interviews regarding the Gary Project and Richard Dawson. Today is March 12th, 2026, and I am located in Bloomington, Indiana, and Rick, you are in?
Rick March: Portland, Oregon.
Julie Stout: Portland, Oregon! And I'm excited about this, this next interview, because it's focused primarily on Richard Dorsen himself, and your memory of him, encounters with him, etc. So, without further ado, I can dive right in.
Julie Stout: To the first question, if that works for you.
Rick March: Okay?
Julie Stout: Okay. You mentioned this a bit in your past… in our past interviews and parts together, but your first encounter with Dawson, when and how did you first meet him, and what were your earliest impressions?
Rick March: Okay, let's see, that would have been in 1973.
Rick March: And, I remember… needing to…
Rick March: You know, I was… I was… see, at that point, I had come back to the States and was staying in Wisconsin and Madison at my, my mother-in-law's house, and, getting ready to, you know, make the move, to Bloomington.
Rick March: And so I… I forget exactly what the business I had to take care of at IU prior to, prior to, moving down there, but I… I drove down to Bloomington.
Rick March: And it was in the summertime. It was, a nice, you know, August, maybe, or early September, hot, humid day. And,
Rick March: I got a little bit fooled by the fact that Indiana is in the eastern time zone, and I was in, the, you know, the central.
Rick March: And, so I drove down, and, you know, wound up… arriving…
Rick March: let's see, what was it? No, no, wait a second, it was the other way around. It was because I… I thought that it was going to be the eastern time zone, but that was back in the days when Indiana didn't change. I arrived… I made an appointment to see Dorsen, and I arrived an hour early.
Rick March: And it was, like, at, you know, 9 AM. It was right when the Institute was gonna open. So I arrived at, you know, what I thought was 9am, but it was 8 AM.
Rick March: And so I was sitting there, nobody was around, and this was when it was in the house on Fess, you know, this little brick house, and I was sitting on the porch, and
Rick March: You know, wondering, well, okay, I guess I haven't missed the appointment. And anyway, so, pretty soon, Dorsen comes, you know, padding up, and, sees me sitting there, and, and, you know, says, oh, hi, and, you know, unlocks the door, and, we go in. And,
Rick March: you know, I guess, I guess he would have been, what, in his, 50s still then, 1973.
Rick March: you know, he… he… he was a relatively diminutive guy, you know, I'm not sure his height may be 5'7", or 8, and, you know, I'm 6'4", so I power over him.
Rick March: He was… he was wearing…
Rick March: I think he was wearing shorts and, like, a polo shirt, so again, you know, not… not formal. Coming… coming to… to work at this office that, you know, when we went up there, I… I realized that the building had been a, you know, a former
Rick March: residential house that had been converted into offices. And those kind of places are always very,
Rick March: improvised, shall we say, you know, there's… there's things on the windowsills, and so on and so forth. And his place was, you know, his office was pretty jam-packed with stuff, and his desk was piled up with lots of things. So anyway, I'm… I'm unable to bring to mind the exact business that I had with him.
Rick March: But, you know…
Rick March: I guess… I think maybe it had to do with my signing up to be a folklore major, or something like that, because I was admitted to the university as a fellow of the, Russian and East European Institute.
Rick March: That was, you know, through whom I was getting the Ford Fellowship.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: So, you know, we chatted, and you know, he struck me as a congenial guy, you know, and
Rick March: the… the whole thing, you know, went well. I… I think… I think that's what it was. It was… I was signing up to be in the folklore program as one of the… one of the initially, master's students.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: you know, the next time that I saw him would have been, you know, a few weeks later, when classes started, and…
Rick March: I, had the pro seminar in Folklore…
Rick March: let's see, Pro Seminar, I can't remember what the… I think just Pro Seminar and Folklore. And, you know, I think I mentioned in an earlier interview that Darson taught the first semester, and Glassie taught the second semester at that time in 1973. And,
Rick March: what I realized about Dorsen, quite quickly.
Rick March: Is that he had this passion, this… this mission in life.
Rick March: to make the field of folklore a respected academic discipline, just like history that he was educated in, just like English, just like classics, whatever. And… and,
Rick March: At that point, it was in the U.S, maybe only, only,
Rick March: Indiana and Penn had PhD programs, and there was a master's program in UCLA.
Rick March: And at Berkeley, I think.
Rick March: But there, you know, there were very few… Oregon, maybe, with, there were very few, academic programs. And Dorsen was really out of the, you know, his motivations were in the traditional academic sphere.
Rick March: You know, I got to know later, you know, from him, that he had attended Exeter, which was this very ritzy, private prep school, you know, in the East.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: I don't know if he mentioned it, or somebody else mentioned it, that he was the first Jewish student ever to attend there. He, you know, went there, started there, let's see.
Rick March: it would have been probably, like, the late 1920s, you know, or 1930, maybe. And,
Rick March: So, you know, and from there, he went on to Harvard.
Rick March: And, you know, he… was in that, you know, that very, elite, element. But, his…
Rick March: His inclinations, he… he kind of liked
Rick March: you know, I… as… as people that I think, you know, had… I think… I think his… his politics, although we never really discussed specific politics, his politics were kind of on the liberal side, and he, like, the common man, we would have said, then we didn't say… we didn't… we were, weren't,
Rick March: Man was the unmarked gender for meaning
Rick March: male, or female, or anything else. So, he,
Rick March: Struck me as the kind of a guy Would have been…
Rick March: really good at going to a cocktail party with… with the dean, or some deans, and shaking hands, and saying, hey, you know, you oughta, you know, think about throwing some more positions the folklore way, you know, you know, I think, you know, we… you know, he was… he was that kind of an advocate for it.
Rick March: What… I realized in his… in his pro seminar.
Rick March: That what he was teaching us, he was very…
Rick March: persnickety about, you know, following the, was it the Chicago, form? You know, you had to do your footnotes in exactly this way.
Julie Stout: Oh, like, the citation, the citation style.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, the Chicago style, and that was in the field of history.
Rick March: predominant, and he actually was, you know, mortified, did not like the… I don't forget the name of the style, where, you know, you put the citation in parentheses right after the sentence.
Julie Stout: Like, APA and MLA, I think, do that.
Rick March: Yeah, okay, that, that, yeah, so that, that was, that was… And the, the scholars who came into the field of folklore out of social science fields.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: to use that, and he… he didn't like it. He really didn't like it. And so, he told us, you know, for folklore, you have to use the Chicago style, and this is how it is, and
Rick March: And, you know, it was a very pragmatic kind of, course, in that, you know, then he said, okay, when you're taping an interview, you know, as soon as you press record, you gotta do just what we did at the beginning, where you, you slate it. And,
Rick March: And, we had, every week.
Rick March: there was an assignment for… I can't remember if it was only one of us, or if it was maybe two or three of us, had to, present a talk.
Rick March: On a… on a folklore topic.
Rick March: And, as, as it happened.
Rick March: I had had a number of occasions when I got janitorial jobs as a quick, easy way to get a side job, you know, as a student and so forth. You know, I was… I was handy with a dust mop and, you know, cleaning windows and so forth. So,
Rick March: When I came down to Bloomington to make a little extra money, I approached
Rick March: a guy, you know, I saw there was, like, janitorial service in the Yellow Pages, and I called him up, and, he asked me to come and visit him, and he was living in a trailer park, kind of on the south edge of the city, and
Rick March: he, was named Roberts, one of those really common Bloomington names. There were certain names like Deckard and Roberts and Robertson and Richardson that, you know, the local families that weren't there because of the university, you know, had…
Rick March: So, anyway,
Rick March: You know, I talked to him for a while, and, you know, he hired me and told me to show up, and I had these various jobs. Mainly, he was going in and cleaning either the offices of stone companies.
Rick March: they got a lot of, dust, the limestone companies on the south side of Bloomington, or… or bars, Army's 500 bar on the near west side, you know, and kind of a grudgy gold,
Rick March: bar that, we had a big Florida mop in there. So anyway, the point… the reason I'm bringing that up is that,
Rick March: what I, what I wound up doing is getting called in on a job where we, about 4 of us, and except for me, the other 3 guys were…
Rick March: were definitely, you know, southern Indiana, you know, what we called, you know, Stonies in those days, you know, guys that, you know, spoke with a southern accent and, you know, the whole thing.
Rick March: So… We got hired to clean, at the windows at a sorority.
Rick March: And the guys that, you know, they were so excited, oh boy, you know, we're gonna go inside a sorority house, you know, where there are all those, those gorgeous, you know, college co-eds, you know. And, you know, I'm going, okay, fine. And,
Rick March: They,
Rick March: you know, they were very, very, you know, how should I say, sexually excited about it, because
Rick March: They were saying, boy, oh boy, you know, like, if, if, if one of them, them students, you know, came walking out of the shower with just a towel wrapped around her walk, I… I don't know, I would just, you know, I would just go to pieces, you know? They were, you know, they're… so the… I… I was noticing, I was noticing the,
Rick March: This…
Rick March: socioeconomic kind of, you know, these are, at a sorority house, the daughters of the upper crust. These guys are, are, you know, hillbilly janitors from, you know, the local Bloomington community.
Rick March: And, and they…
Rick March: Wound up dealing with this situation in the course of it by telling some jokes.
Rick March: And I… I was really interested in kind of the order in which these jokes came, and
Rick March: I wound up, you know, after the fact, I wasn't taping or anything at the time, but I wound up, after the fact, taking a notebook and writing down, you know, some of the comments that the guys made, and there were 3 main jokes that were clearly, you know, previously decided upon jokes.
Rick March: And, So I gave my presentation.
Rick March: And Dawson just loved it.
Rick March: He just loved it, because it was his kind of thing. It was about, you know, a narrative folk art. He likes jokes, you know? He was a good conversationalist and joke teller himself.
Rick March: And I think that it was at that point
Rick March: Even though, you know, he… I wasn't a TA for him or anything yet, because I was supported by the Russian East European Institute.
Rick March: But, he, he noticed me, and was in touch with me, and, you know, asked me about various, you know, at one point, he asked me about getting a, an assistantship, and I said, well, I'm still supported by the,
Rick March: Russian and East European Institute, so, you know,
Rick March: you know, you're barking at the wrong tree this time, but I'm sure the time may come.
Rick March: So, What I realized about him, though, was that
Rick March: He did not indulge in theory at all. He… good writing was his point. You have to write well.
Rick March: And, academics are horrible writers, their sentences are too long, you have to know when to put in a period and start a new sentence with a capital letter. You know, he,
Rick March: And then standards. Standards of, okay, you do need to, when you're… when you're printing these things, you don't rewrite the story like the Grimm brothers did. You…
Rick March: present it verbatim the way the person told it. That, you know, you can do some limited editing, but, you know, basically it's verbatim. And, so, you know, so many of his books are these verbatim texts.
Rick March: With his little headnote that, you know, gives it some context.
Rick March: And, he classified stuff that didn't follow, you know, his guidelines as fake lore.
Rick March: And fake lore was how, you know, he… the first time that he said about making a name for himself. He was gonna be the guy who
Rick March: You know, we would joke about it.
Rick March: Good.
Rick March: be the folklore police, you know, that this is real, and that is fake lore. And, you know, what he chose to attack, of course, was Paul Bunyan stories. Paul Bunyan was this
Rick March: giant logging… logger… now, see, you have to remember, also, he went… he was at… was it Michigan or Michigan State? I'm thinking Michigan State. He was at Michigan State before he got hired at Bloomington.
Rick March: And so, right after his PhD, at first he was in Michigan, and some of his first field work was in the Upper Peninsula of Michigan. Again, he also had the romantic idea, a guy, you know, born and raised in New York.
Rick March: that the folk are off in these, you know, isolated rural areas. And, you know, in Michigan, I think he even wrote about it in the introduction to,
Rick March: what was it? Bear Walkers and…
Rick March: Oh, yeah, yeah. Bloodstoppers and Bear Walkers, I think, is the title of that book. He,
Rick March: that, that for him, going up to the Upper Peninsula, crossing the, you know, Strait of Mackinac, and going up to there, represented going into, you know, exotic territory. And, you know, and he, he, he did, he did reasonable,
Rick March: field work, It, you know, So…
Rick March: Paul Bunyan, then, is, you know.
Rick March: kind of… because he's a lumberjack, was set in that region, and then it was actually, like, there was this,
Rick March: Red River… Something… some company… There was a,
Rick March: Yeah, he was the symbol, you know, like, for certain vegetables, it was the jolly green giant.
Rick March: I forget which vegetable company has the Jolly green giant, but the, you know, the kind of advertising that was prevalent in that era. Oh, yeah, we're gonna have this whole thing with Paul Bunyan and his big blue ox babe.
Rick March: And, and had various stories that were essentially created by,
Rick March: advertising writers. And so he thought, here's this big, juicy target that I'm going to debunk. And so Dorsen, you know, spent… he spent time, you know, in our
Rick March: or a seminar, you know, talking about fake lore, and how Paul Bunyan was, you know, a prime example of it, and it's our duty to, to fight against these things.
Rick March: And, that was… that was one of his… that was one of his crusades, you know, along with making
Rick March: you know, folklore, respectable academic. The other thing was,
Rick March: you know, coming more from the side of the folklore spectrum that Bess Hawes and John Lomax came from, they were political radicals, leftists.
Rick March: Who seized upon, you know, folk music particularly, as the, you know, expression of, you know, the working class.
Rick March: And, actually, Dick Royce, who was a student just before me, he preceded me. I don't think we overlapped in grad school. Dick Royce did a PhD dissertation on
Rick March: The, folklore and, and left-wing politics.
Rick March: And, Dorsen also wanted to, you know, get away from that.
Rick March: In fact,
Rick March: there was… there was some kind of a article he did about that. There was the National Defense Education Act, was a… was a source of funding of grants for people to do research.
Rick March: And, so to promote that folklore wasn't, wasn't some weird, you know.
Rick March: a bunch of far-out, weird lefties, and deserving to receive the National Defense Education Act, you know, he… he was promoting, yeah, that we… we,
Rick March: Keep overt politics out of… out of folklore.
Rick March: So that was… so, you know, I learned in… you know, I got a sense of who the guy was, and what were some of his important priorities, and his sense of advancing in the field, but absolutely, you know, not in terms of theoretical stuff.
Rick March: He was a historian, you know, and historians… it's not that they don't have an underlying theory.
Rick March: In their work, but they don't… they don't usually write theoretical work.
Rick March: they…
Rick March: write historiography kind of studies that explain, you know, techniques and so on and so forth, and questions of that nature. but, it's… it's nothing like…
Rick March: you know, in the social sciences, where, you know, at the time that I was entering grad school, you had Claude Levy Strauss, who was very fashionable out of anthropology from France. You had Del Hines, who was at Penn at the time.
Rick March: you know, these, you know, a few more that I could name, Clifford Geertz.
Rick March: It'd be another one. And,
Rick March: Dorsen, just disdained that kind of writing and, didn't participate in it, really, at all.
Julie Stout: He seems very strong and steadfast in his own beliefs that reading about other people's beliefs, do you think that was where maybe the conflict was? Or maybe why his interest was more in…
Julie Stout: let me write about what I want to write, and not center it on… Only theory alone.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, well, I think he felt that insofar as there was any theory… oh, I have another story about this. Insofar as there was any theory, it should kind of emerge out of the work itself.
Julie Stout: Right.
Rick March: and not have to be explicitly stated. Although.
Rick March: he kind of went on a crusade. There was a, a writer named Duncan Emmerich.
Rick March: who put out a book called
Rick March: I think it was called Folklore on the American Land, if I'm not mistaken. You could look that up. But, Dorsen made that, you know, a fakelore boogeyman. He felt, oh, no. You know, there were these various books that had been popular.
Rick March: Emmerich's, I'd say, was… it came out probably the early 70s, and it was kind of on the tail end of it, but there were various books that came out, oh, I don't know, from the 40s into the 60s.
Rick March: that were kind of like a treasury of this or that, you know, and they would have various shorter writings, a treasury of American short stories, a, you know, a treasury of familiar poetry, and
Rick March: Emmerich's book was, you know, more along those lines, and it was… it was illustrated, and… and I think Dawson also, he wanted to be the big name in American folklore, and he wanted his books to be big sellers, and I… I think that, you know, in some sense, he… he felt a rivalry.
Rick March: with Emmerich, and, you know, needed to castigate his work as not
Rick March: You know, correct folklore, not purely short according to, you know, the precepts that he felt were necessary.
Rick March: But at one point, though, I remember…
Rick March: Boy, I'm trying to remember which book it was.
Rick March: he was telling us, you know, that he was going to write a book in which he was going to state his theory of American folklore.
Rick March: And, And… what I…
Rick March: remember when it finally came out and read it, I was like, oh, no, no, it was actually a talk. He gave it… he gave it at AFS. He gave it at AFS, that's where I… and we were waiting to hear his theory of American folklore, and it was like.
Rick March: It… it was almost a… it was almost a… what do they call it as a rose as a rose, a,
Rick March: Yeah, it's not a… Poetology. It was almost… it was almost, you know,
Rick March: The theory of American folklore was that it was formed and shaped by America's unique land and history and society.
Rick March: And we went, okay, that was it. You know, if I'm not mistaken. But, you know, that was, you know, it kind of fits, you know, Frederick Jackson Turner.
Rick March: was a historian that I think he probably studied with. I think Turner was at… or no, maybe he didn't study with him, because I don't remember if Turner was at Harvard or if he was… always at Wisconsin.
Rick March: he was born in, like, Portage, Wisconsin, north of Madison, when that was on the frontier, and he developed what was called the Frontier Theory of American history, that American history, you know.
Rick March: unfolded the way it did because we had this frontier, and we kept advancing across the continent until the Pacific Ocean.
Rick March: And, so, you know, I, I see Dawson as really coming, you know, out of, out of thinkers like that, and, you know, his, his, his big, his big accomplishments were, were,
Rick March: You know, in this particular
Rick March: era in the 1960s and 70s, a lot of more marginal fields in academ, you know, were being
Rick March: funded, and, you know, that's when all of a sudden women's studies came in in the 70s. African American Studies, you know, these, programs that were outside of the, the, the well-established disciplines.
Rick March: And, and Folklore was benefiting from
Rick March: you know, kind of an openness at the time from the deans to, you know, put some more into that. Folklore itself, the folklore department itself, didn't have very many positions. You know, it may have been only, you know, 4 or 5.
Rick March: But there were, oh, at least a dozen more professors that were cross-listed in folklore who were, you know, in the English department, but liked, you know, folk literature, or were, you know, in the history department, and liked, medieval, legends, you know.
Julie Stout: I remember you said that you took classes with, like, in cross-listed classes, correct?
Rick March: Quite a bit, yeah.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, Felix Oynes, I mentioned, and, he was… he was in New Relic Altaic, as was, Ilhan Bashkos.
Rick March: and Estonian, and… and, you know, I was interested… in, you know,
Rick March: mainly at that point in my life, I was mainly interested in learning more about the European cultures and traditions, because I had just come from spending time studying at the University of Sagreb in Croatia.
Julie Stout: Very fresh for you.
Rick March: Yeah, so I was… yeah, so it was… it was great. It was, so anyway, Dawson and I, through all that period of time, my first two years, I took, I took a couple more courses from him, and I realized, you know.
Rick March: There was a, there was kind of… there were kind of cliques, you know, because it was such a big program with about 30 graduate students.
Rick March: there were kind of cliques of about 8 or 10 students each, that were, you know, the… Glassy had the biggest following, probably about 10 students who just loved… Glassy…
Rick March: Is, you know, very eloquent, and, and,
Rick March: you know, kind of philosophical, and was putting, you know, our, I remember at the end of one of his courses, you know, at the end of his pro seminar, he said, words to the effect that
Rick March: when I was over in Ireland, he drew a lot on the fact that he had been in these villages in Ireland prior to, just this time in the 70s, and he… when he wrote the book about the mumming traditions in Ireland.
Julie Stout: Right, right.
Rick March: All silver and no brass.
Rick March: And, he said, oh, you know, I forget the name of the guy, but, you know, this Irish villager told me that, it… it must…
Rick March: Take a lot of pluck to be the first one to try to use a certain medicinal herb.
Rick March: You know, and then he took that analogy then and said, you know, and I want to see if, you know, we can have the pluck
Rick March: to take folklore, and use folklore as… as this, as this herb that can, you know, benefit our, you know, society, and so on and so forth.
Rick March: You know, so…
Rick March: you know, it was cool, it was cool. It was, you know, he, he, I said, okay, okay, you came up with a really, a really good,
Rick March: rhetorical, statement there. So, anyway, but, you know, Dawson was basically saying, you know.
Rick March: go find good stories. His fieldwork technique that he was telling you is kind of, well, you go to a place, and maybe you'll go to the… if there's a public library, you go and talk to the librarian and see if, you know, he or she knows of anybody who's a good talker, and… and
Rick March: you know, maybe you'll go to a church, or maybe, you know… he didn't emphasize going to things like taverns, incidentally. That's interesting, because I don't… I think he was… that wasn't a comfortable setting for him. He wasn't a teetotaler by any means, but .
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: But I… I do…
Julie Stout: He also wanted to be in the field, though, to some extent. He wanted to talk to the people, it seems.
Rick March: Oh, absolutely, absolutely. No, he felt… he felt field work was a necessity, that a folklorist who didn't do field work wasn't a real folklorist. That was one of his roles. You had to do original folklore, or field work, and and, you know,
Rick March: At his early phase of it, it was still, you know, with a notebook and writing down what people were saying as best you could, and then, you know, recording equipment came in when he was already, you know, into his career.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: Sure.
Rick March: And, .
Julie Stout: And, oh, I have a very quick question.
Julie Stout: In the years that you knew him, in what ways did you work with him, like, in terms of your relationship? Like, he was your teacher, obviously, and then would you say he was, like, a colleague or a collaborator on the Gary Project, or how would you describe how the relationship kind of changed over time, or remained the same?
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, I think, you know, there was always that professor-to-student dynamic, you know, as,
Rick March: You know, here he was. He was almost as old as my parents.
Julie Stout: And.
Rick March: he…
Rick March: you know, the department, he remained, you know, what I learned much later is, that, you know, it's much more typical for the chairs of departments to kind of rotate, so that somebody remains chair for, you know, 3 or so years, and then, you know, somebody else takes it over.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: because they don't want all the bureaucratic duties that come with it. But Dorison remained chair of the folklore program for, I don't know, ages, I don't know, that's probably… For a long time. Yeah. And he… he liked to wield the power in it.
Julie Stout: Mmm…
Rick March: He liked to, he liked to be able to dole out, you know, the assistantships, or half-assistantships, or he, he had, like, my friend Jim Leary was… there was a… there was an assistantship that was his bibliographic
Rick March: assistant. I forget exactly what it was called, but essentially, this, you know, was an assistantship where, you know, Larry was assigned to go and, ransack the library, essentially, you know, find,
Rick March: As many… as many folklore-relevant citations as… as possible, you know?
Rick March: write them up in a big, you know, kind of annotated bibliography.
Rick March: So, and I, I think Dawson's effort in that, you know, direction was influenced by Stiff Thompson.
Julie Stout: You know, Seth Thompson had lived in this house that was also on FESS a couple of.
Rick March: about a block down, and we… that's where we had the TA's offices and stuff, and the Folklore Archives were in there for… it moved into a better building while I was still in grad school during those four years, but there was actually, instead of Thompson's,
Rick March: living room, where we did a bunch of stuff, and, you know, we found out that he… he had
Rick March: created the tail-type index by having this very large, like, Lazy Susan on a round table, and he had little cardboard, boxes where he had index cards. You know, he had index cards, he was reading various,
Rick March: published folklore, you know, folk tales of so-and-so, wherever they are. He would find them, and then he would identify the tail type.
Rick March: write out a, an index card, and, spin the table around until it got to, you know, France, or wherever that was, you know.
Julie Stout: And you put it in.
Rick March: And put it in. And, so, you know, again, Dorsen's coming out of a tradition of that kind of thing, so, you know, having… having a… an assistant, you know, a research assistant that's doing nothing but assembling,
Rick March: You know, citations was, you know.
Rick March: You know, fit right in.
Rick March: Plus, you know, he wanted to collaborate… he collaborated with scholars from all over the world, you know, whatever the folklorists were in, you know, he did folklore of Japan, you know, met some Japanese scholars, had them select
Rick March: you know, folk tales that could be translated into English, and he could write head notes for, and there it was.
Julie Stout: There you go.
Rick March: He did a whole lot of books like that, where he wrote an introduction, and he wrote headnotes to translated folktales.
Rick March: And, you know, so I would say that, you know, again, you know, I was… I was always a student, but I was a student that he seemed to, you know, think favorably of, and .
Julie Stout: I remember you mentioned how you, like, your writing style meshed well with him, if I remember correctly?
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, I agreed with the notion that it's better to write in a way that any, at least, any educated person.
Julie Stout: Good job.
Rick March: could understand. And, you know, and I actually, even fairly recently was asked to do a review of a book,
Rick March: was it for… I think it was for, I think my McDowell had me do it for
Rick March: Jiffy, or… is that… do you still… what is it, Journal of Folklore Institute, or…
Julie Stout: Yes, it is, yes, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, I think that's who I did it for, and but it was… I think it was only online. And I complimented what was good about this book. It was on a topic I knew very well. It was Tumbrits, actually. I complimented what he did well, but then I critiqued
Rick March: It for being written in very hard-to-parse
Rick March: Homo language. He went even to the point of creating a little symbol
Rick March: that was supposed to… so that, you know, he couldn't just deal with the 26 letters of the alphabet. He had to put in a little symbol. I don't know if you're… you're not old enough, maybe, to understand that it's like Prince, when Prince made a,
Rick March: Prince was this, kind of, well, I don't know, a black, sort of rhythm and blues, artist, set of, sort of pop artist.
Rick March: who always wore purple, and then he, he, created a little symbol that represented his name, and it had no pronunciation. So, I… I felt that, you know, this… this…
Rick March: And the trouble was, you know, I realized this book was probably from a dissertation, and it was from… oh, I'm trying to remember right now. It was from one of the… one of the fairly elite, Eastern colleges.
Rick March: And I said, you know, while he has done this and written this thing where you have, you know.
Rick March: page upon page that are really unintelligible to me, and I think I'm a fairly educated person.
Rick March: It was probably exactly what his, professors encouraged in writing his dissertation, because…
Julie Stout: There you go, yeah. You know?
Julie Stout: Princess, sir.
Rick March: Yeah, so anyway, so Dorsen, yeah, Dawson, I think, you know, it…
Rick March: I wasn't… I wasn't, that, interested in… in plunging, you know, so much in-depth into theory, but also felt… you had… you had to have theory, and you had to… you had to acknowledge…
Rick March: you know, what your thinking process was about the material.
Rick March: Because, you know, it affects, you know, what gets noticed and collected, it affects, then, you know, you're constantly narrowing the scope. I mean, there's the phenomenon out there that is yay big.
Rick March: There's the part of it that you go and, document.
Rick March: And then, within your documented material, there are the little slices that inform your, you know, what you present and how you analyze it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So it's, so, you know, it is, it is necessary to, you know, have theory, and I think Dawson
Rick March: although he probably wouldn't have acknowledged that he was doing that, had that. He had that. But, you know, it was more along the lines of, you know, this is a good story.
Rick March: And he didn't go in the direction of somebody like, oh, Ellen Dundees, again, who was a colleague at that time, a little bit younger than Dawson, who was… would ordinarily analyze it in Freudian terms, you know?
Julie Stout: What is…
Rick March: this, what does this reveal, you know, you know, and, in terms of,
Rick March: you know, psychology. You know, there, there were,
Rick March: So, yeah, so anyway, Dawson, you know, we knew he was the department chair, we knew he wielded a lot of power, we knew it was important to not get on the bad side of him, and a few students did get on the bad side of him, and he just didn't like them, and you know, people would get, what was called a terminal master's.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: You know, you'd get the master's and say, bye, you know, you're out of the.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: And, you know, the, so…
Rick March: there were some people that, you know, especially some of the glassy acolytes, and the very few Dag, Linda Dag acolytes,
Rick March: avoided taking any class ever with Dawson after they had… everybody had to take the first seminar.
Julie Stout: Right.
Rick March: But, you know, they,
Rick March: But, you know, I… I… I…
Rick March: what, you know, he… there was a folklore and history course I took. You know, I can't remember them all. I took pretty much…
Rick March: what he taught, through my 4 years in grad school. And.
Julie Stout: Would you, would you say that your personality meshed well with him?
Julie Stout: Or maybe, like, or how would you describe his personality? Like, communication style, temperament, that sort of thing?
Rick March: Yeah, I, I, I think it was necessary…
Rick March: To kind of, humor him, to a
Rick March: I don't think I was… I was… I don't think we… I… I think he was completely… he was completely at ease with me, and was completely himself.
Rick March: But, you know, in some ways,
Rick March: You know, especially in the Gary project, you know, being… being from the south side of Chicago as a kid, and and, you know, being…
Rick March: you know, I guess just a fairly urban person. Not that he wasn't urban from New York, but from a whole different kind of urbanity.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rick March: That… that there were a lot of things that
Rick March: I felt like I had to clue him in, you know, that he just didn't get.
Julie Stout: Oh, like, social dynamics, or like…
Rick March: Yeah, a lot of that, too, so… not only that, or,
Rick March: You know, just navigating city life, having some street smarts, and he…
Rick March: You know, he was a little bit like a naive and, you know, a babe in the woods, in Gary to some extent.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: you know, it, it, it showed that kind of, you know, like in his earliest field work, he, he went right away to, IU Northwest.
Rick March: He met, a couple or three, professors there, and they were… they were among his… his first, you know, inns into… into the area, which,
Rick March: okay, you know, it's the world that he comes from, it stands to reason. So, you know, a lot of the time, you know, aside from also dealing with his health, you know, it was,
Rick March: You would have these, these, these problems where
Rick March: You know, he'd be in the car, usually he would have us drive. And he had these occasions where his esophagus would collapse.
Rick March: And, you know, and he'd be choking. And, you know, you know, Dr. Dressling, what can we do? And, you know, he'd choke off that, you know, okay, get me to a place, I have to have a cup of Senka.
Rick March: You know, he couldn't drink caffeine because of his heart condition and so forth.
Rick March: But, You know.
Rick March: there were things that were likable about him. He, you know, he was, he wasn't, arrogant, he was, in, you know, in interpersonal relations.
Rick March: he was arrogant about, you know, that he had the views, that, you know, he definitely wanted to be known as the father of American folklore.
Julie Stout: And he got his wish! It's listed on Finding Aids in the archive and everything, so…
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, yeah, he managed to do that, and
Rick March: And, you know, he drove himself so hard.
Rick March: To achieve that, and that, you know, he… you know, with the heart condition he had, that he…
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: died relatively young. The fact that he was out there with the heart condition that he had, playing tennis.
Rick March: And a hot day, you know… That was, D.
Rick March: you know, indicative. A lot of… a lot of people with… in his physical condition would… would have, you know, gone to playing croquet or something, not…
Julie Stout: Yeah, it was… Oh, he was proud!
Rick March: He was proud of the fact that he competed in Ivy League squash.
Rick March: Squash is a game that is with a tennis-type racket, smaller.
Julie Stout: It's…
Rick March: Indoors, with two walls, and you can… you can bounce the ball off of, you know, you carry them off of these different walls.
Julie Stout: as you play against.
Rick March: a squad… that he was, he was a, you know, I don't know if he won any, any championships or anything, but that he was, he was a…
Rick March: An athlete, you know?
Julie Stout: It plays…
Rick March: played squash for Harvard, or… I think it was at Yale for a while, too. Might have been for Yale, I'm not sure. But, in any case, yeah, that's all lookable, but,
Rick March: And, You know, There was a lot of…
Rick March: bad-mouthing of Dorsen behind his back among, you know.
Rick March: grad students, and, you know, he… he had some, you know, peculiarities that it was easy to criticize. And, but, you know.
Rick March: I, I acknowledged… I acknowledged, you know.
Rick March: shortcomings, and I acknowledged his… his sometimes… What would be the word?
Rick March: You know, sometimes judgmental things, oh, that's fake lore, or, you know,
Rick March: that he could be arbitrary sometimes. I recognize that he had those, but, you know, on the whole, you know, none of us are perfect, and.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: I saw him as a guy who, you know, followed a particular passion. He was fortunate to have had
Rick March: the advantages of, you know, going to this, you know, prep school, Exeter, going to, you know, Harvard and Yale, I think, too. And,
Rick March: And… You know, being able to just, at that era, step right into a tenure-track professor job.
Julie Stout: Bye.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: And he, you know, he knew the academic system, and he tried to play it for all it was worth to establish folklore as a, you know, a respected academic field.
Rick March: And, you know, for that reason, you know, that's why he was… he had his standards, and people that didn't seem to follow his standards, he… you wish to make them go away.
Julie Stout: You, noted earlier that you had, like, an anecdote you wanted to share, so I wanted to ask you about…
Julie Stout: Anecdotes that reveal his actual, like, character.
Julie Stout: Whether that be positive, difficult, or complex, I'd like to know what he was like to work with.
Rick March: Well, you know.
Rick March: I think I told the anecdote about how he wanted to make his own recording of the.
Julie Stout: Yes.
Rick March: story that I recorded.
Julie Stout: Yep, in the church, and how he was, like.
Rick March: Yeah.
Julie Stout: He fainted, and he rushed, and he still went to the church anyways, and with.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, we did have to, you know, those of us
Rick March: I probably… I probably did it a bit more than any of the other, you know, Gary Gang members, you know, being in this situation where I'm driving around with Carson in the car.
Julie Stout: Right, right, yeah.
Rick March: There, there, you know, other people did it, too. I think I did it maybe a little more.
Rick March: Maybe because he was comfortable with me, and, you know, I was… I was comfortable with him. It's just, you know, you had to be… you had… again, it was that student-to-professor relationship, and, you know, you always had… you know, it's kind of like, you know, in… in the language that I studied in…
Rick March: Croatia, there's two forms of how you say you.
Rick March: You know, just like in Spanish, there's usted and tu.
Julie Stout: All, like, formal and informal.
Rick March: Formal and informal? Yeah, so I was always kind of on the American English equivalent of having that.
Julie Stout: Thank you.
Rick March: It comes in… it comes in the tone, in the wording, in the, you know… you know, I never would have said to him if he says, oh, that's a bunch of bullshit. Yeah, Dr. Garrison, you're so bullshit, you know, which I might have said to, you know, somebody that was really at a colleague level with.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: And, you know, and we were pretty good friends that they wouldn't, you know, be horribly insulted by that. Of course.
Julie Stout: Yes.
Rick March: But I never, so, yeah, there always was that… that degree of… there's a… there's a power relationship that is… is unspoken, but it's definitely recognized that, you know, he's running the program I'm in.
Rick March: He became the chair of my, dissertation committee. He, you know, was running the Gary Project.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: you know, it was clear to us that he wanted to write a book and have, you know, that's why he wanted, you know, a good story recorded by him, so he could stick in the book as recorded by Richard M. Dawson.
Rick March: And, you know.
Rick March: So, you know, you recognize, okay, okay, well, he's getting something that he needs from me, and I'm getting something that I need from him.
Julie Stout: Like a Bennett, like a mutually benefit…
Rick March: Mutual beneficial.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: you know, you know, not, egalitarian. There was definitely something of a hierarchy, but nonetheless, he was benefiting from my work and my insights and steering him into things that, you know, here's a good place to do something. Or, you know, like, like when,
Rick March: And… and also the fact that
Rick March: I was… I was one of the avid, EV creators.
Julie Stout: And…
Rick March: You know, with the videotape,
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: You know, other, other people created some things, too. I would say Adler and Hassie, were, you know, two more that, that, you know, were very interested in doing the,
Rick March: the video. But, you know,
Rick March: You know, what can I say?
Rick March: it's, you know, I think in an earlier conversation, we said it's… it was totally normal, and probably still is, but especially then, that, a professor would, advance, you know, in Dorsen's case, his own career,
Rick March: By benefiting from research that his students had carried out.
Rick March: And, You know, that was… that was understood, and…
Rick March: I… you know, we knew… now, I didn't decide I was gonna go in that direction, but if I had come back from Europe for my Fulbright.
Rick March: If I had come back to Bloomington, I'm confident he would have given me some kind of an assistantship, probably a research assistantship of some sort, because the teaching assistantships tended to go to people that weren't as far along as having
Rick March: completed their, relives.
Rick March: But, but it would be kind of like, oh, you know, I'll be kind of at his beck and call.
Rick March: And that, that was, you know, you know, I could have tolerated, but I, I didn't really want to. And I, you know, was thinking more in line. You know, I, right after, right after,
Rick March: kind of the end of the Gary Project in 77, Elena Berdunas, who had been in the Gary Project, you know, had just been hired at the, Center for American Folklife at the, Library of Congress, and she wanted to do a project
Rick March: that, you know, she admitted was like the Gary Project, but done
Rick March: the right way, you know, in Chicago. And she was… she was from Chicago, she was from the Lithuanian community, on the southwest side, Marquette Park neighborhood, which is now mostly Latino, but then it was mostly Lithuanians.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: she, she hired me and a bunch of other people to come and do, you know, a couple or three weeks worth of field work in a particular… it was a Chicago ethnic folklore project, something like that.
Rick March: And it was clearly modeled on the Gary project, and, you know, it might be something that, for your… you might want to look up. There are… there are some things, you know, there's, like, a long interview I did
Rick March: with a tambour, it's a maker that was… somebody sent me a link to on the Library of Congress site. You know, so there's… there's stuff there as an example of something that was clearly derivative of the Gary project, you know.
Julie Stout: Do you remember the name of the project?
Rick March: Yeah, something like the Chicago Ethnic Arts, or Chicago Ethnic Folk Arts Project, something along those lines, and Elena Bardunis's name, probably, as director of it.
Rick March: So, and it was… it was done in 1977, 78.
Julie Stout: Chicago Ethnic Arts Project.
Rick March: There it is.
Julie Stout: There it is, it's still online!
Rick March: There it is, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, so, the,
Rick March: You know, again, we, we,
Rick March: you know, we worked… you know, I feel like, you know, I… I see from 73 to… he died in 81, what, the 8 years? You know, I knew him for 8 years, although I was gone part of the time when I went to Europe.
Rick March: But, you know, I was still in touch with him a bit as the chair of my, my dissertation committee, sent him some letters about what I was doing.
Rick March: But, you know, I feel like I got to know the man pretty well, and,
Rick March: I, I, I saw… I saw a… a…
Rick March: a human and appealing aspect to him, and I saw a, you know,
Rick March: A guy who was in charge, who had power over, over, you know, meat.
Julie Stout: Right.
Rick March: various ways, and I had to be, careful not to… not to kick him off, you know?
Julie Stout: No, 100%, yeah. Especially when he's, like, the… he's the chair in your committee, he's involved in your project. Yeah, exactly.
Rick March: And… and if I was going for, like, an academic job, getting a strong recommendation from him would have been, like, absolutely, you know, necessary.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: you know, at the time, as he was establishing himself as the father of American folklore, to, you know, get a strong recommendation on a job application would have been, important.
Julie Stout: 100%.
Rick March: Yeah.
Julie Stout: And… oh, sorry.
Rick March: So, you know, yeah, that's… I don't know. You go ahead and ask me something else.
Julie Stout: Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah. You mentioned…
Julie Stout: his, like, famous line of, like, I wrote this many books, for when he wants people to, like, introduce him, and he wants people to know about the legacy that he's trying to place, essentially. And I wanted to ask you about legacy and your view on his legacy.
Julie Stout: How has your view of Dawson's contributions and controversies, if you think there even are any, evolved over time? And what should students and future researchers understand about his impact and the complexities of his legacy?
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, he is…
Rick March: legacy is, I don't know, well over 30 books, by the time he wound up.
Rick March: He assembled… A great deal of…
Rick March: Well-presented folk materials, mainly, narratives.
Rick March: He…
Rick March: you know, established, established criteria. You know, it had… it had been the norm, you know, starting from Brothers Grimm for
Rick March: The, you know.
Rick March: People who publish these books to be writers who rewrote the story as, you know, literary prose.
Rick March: And so, you know, I think that he… that was… an important contribution was he was… he was maybe the most important voice for, you know, let the words of the folk informant, he was… he would call it…
Rick March: Let the informant's words, you know, stand for themselves, you know, and we'll come in on a head note.
Rick March: I think… His legacy of establishing folklore programs at universities has been eroded.
Julie Stout: I was too.
Rick March: since the 1980s, you know, things turned around in terms of these, you know, university programs like, you know, women's studies, African American Studies, all of these things that were, kind of
Rick March: pressed upon university administrators by the turbulence of the times in the 60s and early 70s. You know, they have the show, yeah, we're responding to the demands of women, we're responding to the demands of, you know, regional minorities.
Rick March: And, you know, that is, you know, sadly,
Rick March: just gradually been eroded, so there are fewer and fewer programs. And,
Rick March: Most of the jobs for people in folklore are not, you know… you have to… you have to convince someplace that
Rick March: isn't a folklore department at a university, that somebody that has, you know, like, a master's or a PhD in folklore, could be a useful… you have to show… you have to show why you would be useful.
Rick March: Yeah, I can write… I can write good academic articles about folklore. I think that…
Rick March: a whole lot of the students out of the program at Indiana were the early, public folklorists.
Rick March: You know, when, there was, a job opening in, as a stakeholders person, you know,
Rick March: a whole lot of them, Greta Swenson, Blanton, Owen, you know, I could go… I'd have to… I'd have to…
Rick March: Hunder it more, but .
Julie Stout: And yourself!
Rick March: And myself, yes.
Rick March: A whole lot of the people that got hired, yeah, Egla Zigas, and then, you know, Elaine Ibergen is going to Washington.
Julie Stout: Yeah. Good.
Rick March: there were There were a whole lot of us.
Rick March: Because…
Rick March: our program was more, pragmatic than, you know, and that, that is definitely an influence of Dawson. If it was, you know, if Glassie and Dag had been the only professors, it would have been very different.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, oh, what's his name?
Rick March: The guy who went to Florida, yeah, yeah, yeah. Ormond Loomis, yeah, another… you know, there were… there were,
Rick March: A lot of, penn graduates who, you know.
Rick March: didn't get their hands dirty. I remember being kind of appalled by
Rick March: a Penn student doing a paper at AFS about interviewing somebody that had a
Rick March: poster of the Beatles on his room wall, and he interviewed him about, you know, well, what does it make you feel, or, you know, how do you relate to, you know, the faces of, you know, John, Paul, George, and Ringo, you know, affect you? And I said.
Rick March: That was his field work? You know,
Rick March: I think I still had, and most of us had, this notion that you needed to get out of your comfort zone. You needed to go and figure out a good way to get
Rick March: In good graces, with people from a different culture, or, you know, subculture, than you belong to, and… and,
Rick March: You know, develop a greater understanding of that person's culture, you know, through their expressive arts.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: And, and, and if you, if you're, you know.
Rick March: If you neglect to do that, it's… it's eliminating a…
Rick March: really important aspect of what… what folklore can do. I think Elena Brodunis, actually, your name keeps popping up, wrote in that Folklore forum
Rick March: issue that had my thing about how I became the TV man. She wrote one because she did a bunch of work with the Lithuanian community, you know, as I was doing with Serving Crawds, but I didn't feel like they were my community. It was a different city and everything.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rick March: But she was writing a thing about doing fieldwork in your own
Rick March: ethnic group, dealing with what are some of the issues. And there, there are some, because
Rick March: You know, an outside person
Rick March: You know, there might be a term used or something that is very familiar to you, an in-group term, and then you don't ask about it, you don't get a clear definition, and then outside people don't ever get it defined.
Julie Stout: Right.
Rick March: Whereas if, you know, an outside person says, oh,
Rick March: What do you mean by drushva? That's kind of a weird term. I said, oh, oh, yeah, that's how we say, you know, company, and, you know, it has certain connotations, and, you know, you need to… Yeah. The outside person has things explained, in…
Rick March: In a different way than.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: So, again, you know, and Dawson felt field work is important. He established that. He is, you know, he…
Rick March: The,
Rick March: you know, I don't know what the future of the field is going to be in, you know, an ever more difficult academic, environment for it. You know, I…
Rick March: don't know what the situation is, if there are, you know, full-time tenure-track positions in folklore. Probably, if any.
Rick March: A handful at most.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: mostly, mostly, people with folklore degrees are gonna have to hustle up, some kind of an interesting job. I worked… oh, another job that I… I don't know if I mentioned, that I worked at Milwaukee Public Museum. Yeah, I think I did mention it.
Julie Stout: Oh, yeah, but yeah, not your… not your duties within the rule, though, as much.
Rick March: Yeah, my, my, I…
Rick March: a guy who worked in the museum education division, who liked to strum a guitar and sing, you know, folk songs, applied to the NEA Folk Arts program and got a grant to have a series
Rick March: called Folk Arts in Today's America, and, every Saturday for, I don't know.
Rick March: few months, we, had somebody come in, you know, a Slovenian accordion player.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: an Italian seamstress, a Ukrainian Easter egg maker, and so it was kind of my job to do field work.
Rick March: and find, somebody who was interested in and, capable of coming in on a Saturday as a museum educator.
Julie Stout: You know.
Rick March: People would bring their kids in, and we printed up brochures, and .
Julie Stout: There's, like, programming type… type things? Yeah.
Rick March: programming, you saw every So… so there was, you know, a, a workshop that lasted, you know, maybe…
Rick March: I don't know, a couple hours, and then maybe we… sometimes… sometimes I think we repeated it, yeah. We would do one early, and then we'd do one later.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: And the cool thing about working at the museum, it was the… it was a county institution, and, we could, like, when we had the German woodworker, we could have a county truck go over to his house and load up his own workbench.
Rick March: And, you know, haul it over to the museum. And, you know, we could have them working on it, instead of on just some sort of…
Rick March: you know, random, table, like, from a meeting room table. You know, we had his own workbench, and we had… So yeah, it was, again.
Rick March: The possibilities in… in… you know, folklorists have to convince institutions, like museums, and so forth, that they have certain skills that can be important.
Julie Stout: It can be important.
Rick March: important things like, I don't know, rural health programs to get people to, you know, feel comfortable coming into, you know, a clinic, or have, you know, there's just, there's just various, there's various things that, that, that,
Rick March: folklorists could do, and I would say that the graduates of Indiana during Dawson's time were a lot of the pioneers in that.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: You know, later, you know, there were people coming out of Western Kentucky, because they established a specifically public folklore, you know, direction in their program.
Rick March: And, you know, there were some people from Penn and from,
Rick March: you know, UCLA and so forth, you know, so… but, you know, Indiana, I'd say, was dominant
Rick March: And, not because Dorsen liked it, he didn't like it. He wanted us all to be academics, but he also wanted us to be pragmatic and be able to communicate with people beyond, you know, a little group of scholars who knew all the jargon.
Julie Stout: There you go, yeah.
Rick March: I would say that's, you know, his big contribution.
Rick March: And.
Julie Stout: Inadvertently raising the next generation of public folklorists, even though public folklore was not quite something he…
Julie Stout: maybe aligned himself with would be the way to say it.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, his mission was to get folklore into academe.
Julie Stout: Yep.
Rick March: And, and it was kind of an indication of his failure to do it to scale.
Julie Stout: Yeah, I mean?
Rick March: to scale, I mean, in terms of, you know, here you've got 30, grant students with, maybe, you know, a dozen of them finishing their prelims.
Rick March: getting their PhD, you know, in a year, but there weren't anywhere near that many academic jobs to, so, you know, some reluctantly, or in my case,
Rick March: Without any reluctance, gravitated to… to public folklore.
Julie Stout: There you go, yeah.
Rick March: And, and yeah, and those, those basic standards stuck with me. I actually have,
Rick March: you know, kind of drifted a little bit. I started off, essentially, with Dorsen standards. I think most of us did, in terms of, yeah, you gotta present things, you know, verbatim, and, you know, you don't… you don't fake lure things up, but I think that what… what…
Rick March: Most of us in the field have come to realize is that as time goes on, things change.
Rick March: that the people that we're studying are, you know, live in the same existential reality as us. It's not like, oh, I'm the guy from the university, and you're the Rube from the countryside who has all this old lore, you know. It's, you know, we're…
Rick March: We're meeting on a much more equal footing, and it's to find out about, you know, we're interested in various subcultures, and you know, it's… and we also realize that people… a lot of culture is of choice.
Rick March: You know, we were… we, again, were… Highly, highly, prioritized
Rick March: the culture you got with your mother's milk, you know? And, but if somebody, you know, from outside the culture just, you know, totally got into making
Rick March: I don't know, Ukrainian Easter eggs, and worked really hard at it, and you know, became really good at it, you know, that's a significant phenomenon. It's not the same phenomenon as the maker who had grandma teach at.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: It's not the same phenomenon, but if you… if you describe anything accurately, then that's authentic.
Rick March: Authenticity means
Rick March: you're authentically telling what this phenomenon is, and that, you know, we need to be open to, you know, as the phenomenon that was defined as folklore, you know, when I started with Dawson.
Rick March: Diminishes as a segment of, the culture.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: You know?
Rick March: as that diminishes, you know, so then what do we do? Do we only… we keep… we keep those and study a smaller and smaller set of things? Or do we say, oh, let's study…
Rick March: cultural phenomena. That's why, you know, like, we've gone to this term, culture work. Have you seen the public folklore book? It's called culture work. because the whole, the whole word folk is… is laden with,
Rick March: you know, stuff. And,
Rick March: I think it's still a useful word, but, the…
Rick March: Yeah, so all I'm saying is that while Dorsen… Dorsen's standards gave me and many of the other folklorists, most of the other folklorists coming out of Indiana, a grounding.
Rick March: We've evolved from that, in ways that he might find appalling nowadays. But, you know, or he, or he was pragmatic, he might have… he might have evolved along with the times, you know, had he survived another few decades.
Rick March: But.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, but anyway, there he is, Richard M. Dorsen.
Rick March: American folklore, A guy that,
Rick March: Basically congenial person, who had his strong points and some blind spots, and .
Julie Stout: There you go.
Rick March: Decent human being.
Julie Stout: Well, through that entire talk, you inadvertently answered all of my questions that I had for you, but I want to leave the floor open in case you want to add anything, or mention anything, whatever comes to mind.
Rick March: Yeah, I think that your, your questions, although I, I, you know, I just read them over, and
Rick March: I think they're embedded in my mind somewhere, so I got around to most of that. No, I'm really… I'm really pleased that a young
Rick March: Colleague like you has, seen the significance of this project, which,
Rick March: I think has been under, recognized, and that you got on the task while most all of us who participated are still living. The, you know, exception that one student and, of course, the director.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: are gone. But,
Rick March: You know, and I, I think,
Rick March: The fact that you're, you know, you're in… in the information field and,
Rick March: It opens up possibilities that this material may be, you know, more accessible through the technology we have today.
Rick March: You don't have to get on a plane and go to Bloomington and, go rummaging through file cabinets to see anything.
Rick March: So, all that's good.
Rick March: And, you know, it's been a pleasure, working with you, and I hope you, stay in touch a little bit. You're gonna send me some info, and,
Rick March: you know, good luck to whatever happens next after August when you get your master's.
Julie Stout: Will do! Yes! Thank you so much for talking with me, for this last session, and I will definitely, follow up and be in touch and everything.
Rick March: Okay.
Julie Stout: One here, one second.
Rick March: So, good work! We did it…